[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Todd McShay ESPN college football
analyst and draft analyst as well
available now on ESPN plus Todd McShay's
mock drafts Prospect rankings Pro Day
observations also tomorrow ESPN plus Mel
Kuiper and Todd McShay a three-round
alternating NFL mock draft and of course
the the draft coverage
ABC will be the first two days ESPN on
the third day title be involved with
that great to see you again Todd uh is
it a good or bad draft because we don't
know who the first pick is going to be
the bomb drafts I'll say that I feel
more confident today whatever nine days
out right I feel more confident today
than I did 10 days ago on who's gonna be
the number one pick I really think it's
going to be Bryce young you know all the
the information we're getting out of
Carolina and they're trying to keep it
quiet but it's hard when you have the
first pick and it really comes down to
two guys between Alabama's Bryce young
and CJ Stroud from Ohio State
the information is going to get out so I
can't say it's 100 but I feel really
strongly that it's Bryce young at one
now where this class gets really
interesting and if you had asked me 10
days ago or two weeks ago I would have
said it if it's not if it's not young
it's Stroud at one and if it's young at
one it's shrouded too
the more the closer we get to the draft
the more information I'm getting at
Houston is not going to take CJ Stroud
at number two with Bryce young was
available I'm told that they would take
young at two so what does that mean
right
so if Houston stays at two
and takes and takes Will Anderson and
remember jamico Ryan's comes comes in as
the head coach you've got Nick casario
the general manager from Bill Belichick
with the relationship with Nick Saban
and and Domico Ryan's comes from San
Francisco where they built this great
defense and been able to plug in
quarterbacks and get to NFC championship
games and he's a defensive guy with
Alabama Roots so will Anderson would
make sense it too
if you're comfortable with your
quarterback situation which I don't
understand how Houston can be but if
they're not sold on one of these other
quarterbacks then maybe they go Will
Anderson it too and now Arizona
and they went from having a prize pick
at three to having I mean the stock
Rises on it uh just tenfold because now
like I was told that Las Vegas was very
interested and I know for a fact they
tried to get up to number one they
weren't able to get a deal done Carolina
gives up the farm to go up to one and I
was told that they're not interested in
any quarterback not named young or
Stroud but now they're in the mix if
Houston or if Houston goes Will Anderson
Arizona now could trade out and if
Houston sits there too and says you know
what we love will Anderson but what can
we get for this pit and if you're
Houston right and you're going to pass
on Stroud that's one thing but if you're
gonna pass on Stroud and now you're
handing them over to a division Foe and
you've got to face him twice a year
Indianapolis sitting at fourth or or
Tennessee at 11 could LeapFrog uh
Indianapolis and get up to two or three
I would want to control that if I were
Houston I want to make a deal with Las
Vegas move down to seven still get a
great player
but also get additional picks and make
sure that Stroud is not in our division
so that the draft kind of starts at
number two for me yeah I was going to
ask you where the drama started and you
just answered that but also this time of
the year trying to get real information
Todd house because I tell my audience
don't believe anything that any of these
coaches or GM's or owners say right but
what should we believe
well it's funny because every team
that's not in the quarterback Market has
a big opinion
you know I can talk to teams drafting in
the 20s and you know 30 and 31 and
they're they're they love to give your
their opinion on will Levis we wouldn't
take him Anthony Richardson's too big of
a project you know but when you're up
there and you're sitting it for like
Indianapolis you're sitting at seven
like Vegas or 11 in Tennessee and you
need a quarterback they tend to look a
lot better than uh than the teams that
don't need them so
it's tough this time of year obviously I
I lean I lean on my relationships I get
information typically from other teams
that have information or have friends
within those other teams that there's
kind of some leaks and then I always
bounce things off of shefter and
Mortensen because they they're typically
hearing the same things or different
things and try to balance out that
information at this point but it's
difficult I mean the amount of
disinformation that is sped out there
in the public and you see on Twitter and
those sorts of things I'd laugh that
because I get off the phone with the
general manager one day a director of
college scouting the next day and then I
I'm reading these things and I'm like
that's the exact opposite of what
they're saying you know I have a friend
who's a scout who's been a great
resource and I always say to him you
know give me somebody that we should be
keeping an eye on and he's been pretty
good at giving me that guy in the in the
first round but I said what do you think
about Bijan Robinson at Texas he said I
would love to see him as a Debo Samuel
type of player where I can use that
running back that talent but also I can
keep him in the system and not overuse
him as a running back and maybe have
this hybrid here so I don't know if it
feels like we're gun shy with running
backs but he's he's great on Bijan
Robinson is through the roof he said I
love I love the kid he's got great hands
I would love to see him as a Christian
McCaffrey type and McCaffrey could
probably play you know a slot receiver
but I wonder your thought that's on
Robinson in the running back position
Bijan Kim play slot receiver and if you
studied his tape at all and I've got
clip after clip of him in the slot
running not running like you know
underneath routes but getting down the
scene catching in traffic catching the
ball over his head contested situations
he can do all that when I talked to
coach sarkeesian before the TCU game
this this year he said listen we're
trying to limit his touches we're not
trying to wear him out but the catches
he makes in practice like you'd be
shocked like I know there's good game
tape but the things we see in practice
are out of control so I could see him in
more of a hybrid role but I'll say this
I haven't I've got him as the number two
ranked player in this class behind Bryce
young I haven't talked to a team I'm
talking probably close to a dozen teams
that that have him outside of the top
five everyone has them in the top five
in terms of their grades now where does
he fall that's that's the fascinating
part I mean Philadelphia doesn't take a
running back in the top ten they love
taking offensive defensive lineman but
that's the first spot where you can look
and say that might make some sense I
think he's just as talented maybe a
little bit more unique than saquon
Barkley and saquon was the number two
overall pick but you see the you know
the beating and the injuries that saquon
had and you just wonder is it worth it
so it may get down to like 18 to Detroit
21 of the Chargers the Austin Eckler
having issues there yeah and I I still
hold this up Dallas is obsessed with
getting a running back that can be be
their guy be a compliment to Tony
Pollard like they have with Zeke when
Zeke was you know more they're closer to
his prime
Mike McCarthy was dying for a big power
back like that wants to run the football
they want to be a run-based team and
they would love to bring the Texas Star
into Dallas and make him the star of
their offense so Dallas is sitting at
26. it wouldn't shock me if they made a
splash jumped up into the teens ahead of
teams like Detroit and and the Chargers
and went and got Bichon maybe around
like 14 15 16. talking to Todd McShay
ESPN college football an NFL draft
analyst this feels like an I Told You So
draft three years down the road that
somebody's gonna go I told you about
Hendon hooker I told you about Anthony
Richardson good or bad hey I told you
about CJ Stroud do you get that feeling
or is that every year that it feels like
and I told you so three years down the
road I think it's more so than than this
year than it has been in past years
um last year we knew that there was
maybe one quarterback in the first round
the group wasn't very good I think with
the quarterback specifically
after after CJ Stroud and even you know
an NFL team some teams are mixed on CJ
Stroud
I've talked to so many teams that are so
concerned about will Levis and I've
talked to a couple teams that love him
Anthony Richardson we all see it I mean
he's a he's Athena he's he's different
than everyone I've ever evaluated but I
saw it Todd but then I didn't see it
like that's right that's my big concern
I was like damn look at that guy and
then it'd be like oh is Anthony
Richardson playing oh he is so roller
coaster of his draft stock has been
similar to the roller coaster of
watching his tape like I I did the
Kentucky game and so I was fresh off the
Utah game earlier the season after the
Utah game Heisman Trophy number one
overall thing this guy's a better than
Cam Newton you know in his prime and
then I the Kentucky game I'm on the
sideline and first of all it was great
being on the saabon with the Kentucky
defense I I can't use half the words
that were said but every time they got
three and August Heisman Heisman this
Heisman that they had a great plan they
took away the Run they played with
discipline and he looked lost and I was
right after the Utah game with the
45-yard touchdown run and juking the guy
at the last minute to get in into the
end zone and we saw what he can be
physically but then a week later we saw
how inexperienced he is so I'd love to
see him with Shane steichen in
Indianapolis and second has worked with
with Justin Herbert and Jalen hurts and
his developed quarterbacks but do they
have the patience to to wait a year with
Gardner minchio as their starter and so
it so much of it is going to come down
to where these guys wind up going but uh
they're you're right there are a lot of
I told you so it's either good or bad in
this class give me the team that should
draft a quarterback that maybe we're not
keeping an eye on
Minnesota
I think Minnesota should they're sitting
at 23. you've got Kirk Cousins who's
going to turn 35 this summer was 23rd in
qbr a year ago continues to struggle in
in big situations we go back to that
fourth and fourth and you know a few
yards last year and any big game he has
struggled he's got one year left on his
contract it'll be a perfect time to
bring in a bridge quarterback now at 23
they don't have a second round pick so
it's not like they have all this
ammunition to go up and move move to get
one of these top four quarterbacks so it
could be Hendon hooker where they say
you know what maybe we've got an early
second round grade in this guy he had
ACL injury surgery in November maybe
we're at the cinema year but this is the
perfect situation to sit in for a year
the only issue is he's going to be 26 in
January you know it was rookie year so
now you're talking about 27 before
you're putting him on the field but it's
still still a quarterback and if you
draft him in the first round remember
you get that fifth year option so it
makes more sense to take him in the
first so Minnesota I know from people in
the league and sources I have they've
been doing a deep dive kind of quietly
into this quarterback class so it
wouldn't Shock Me late in the first if
they took one of these guys I I'm sure
you remember this Merrill Hodge was
discussing Johnny Manziel and I saw it
on Twitter this week with with Skip
Bayless oh yeah and and you know
was never a hot take guy like he was a
football nuts and bolts tape guy and you
know Skip of course is hot take and you
know haji's like no you don't take this
guy you know not in the first round
second third maybe fifth round and then
skip said you you know you couldn't be
more wrong about that I I'm still
I I think we're all fascinated with
Manziel and how he was so spectacular
but he failed so spectacularly yeah
first of all I'm smoking mirrors that I
got to work with with and jaws and
those guys and you know we would do all
Kuiper and I and a bunch of people in
studio would do all these shows leading
up to the draft and I used to call it
the NFL films biker gang you know
and Josh they'd come rolling into
Bristol like a week before and tear up
all these mock draft ideas
and this guy sucks he can't play you
know but but I love it you know what
more often than not they have they have
really good points but with Manziel
specifically
he was unique to college because he
could get away with things in college
that he couldn't in the NFL and I know
he had his best game against Alabama
which was essentially an NFL defense uh
but but physically there were
limitations that allowed him to be great
in college that where he couldn't pull
it off in the NFL and he got away with a
lot of slop in a lot of backyard
football and when he had to play with
instructure he wasn't there and I think
the most important thing is he just he
was so he had so many things outside
outside influences you know there was a
lot of partying and fun he he loved what
football brought to him I don't think he
truly loved football and was dedicated
to do what you know what Peyton Manning
and Tom Brady and Drew Brees and you
know all the great quarterbacks over
history have done in terms of putting in
the day-to-day grind always great to
talk to you and I look forward to
talking to you again soon thank you Tom
take care Todd McShay ESPN college
football NFL draft analyst and his mock
draft available at ESPN Plus available
tomorrow on ESPN plus Mel Kuiper and
Todd McShay have a three-round
alternating NFL Mock Draft where they
take turns making picks